and i wanted to check in with you two on
the big announce we saw just a few
minutes ago god of war ragnarok we
finally got our first big look at it and
actually eric i wanted to start with you
you've been involved with every single
god of war including 2018's god of war
is that correct
yeah that's correct sid i've been with
the studio since 2004 in many different
capacities working with both santa
monica and radio dawn on the god of war
franchise and
i don't know why but they thought it'd
be a good idea to say hey do you want to
direct this one and so
that's what i'm doing i'm directing god
of war ragnarok or as corey likes to
call it never heard of it so that's the
update on that so eric why the shift in
leadership on god of war ragnarok
it's always been a tradition here at
santa monica to change the directors
across the games you know we've had
really good success with that cory's
been the only repeat director and you
know rightfully so he's pretty damn good
at what he does so that's kind of what
it is
the important thing for us is to be able
to kind of get a fresh perspective each
time
uh but also you know a fresh pair of
legs in the sense that you're really
exhausted at the end of finishing one of
these things so you gotta con somebody
else into doing it like him
so eric what aesthetics or themes sort
of resonate with you as a creative i
mean i guess what i'm getting at is like
how do you see yourself leaving your
fingerprints on god of war ragnarok it's
kind of the designer me wants to answer
one way but as a director you have to
answer a different way i think you have
to learn how to jettison your own a
profession when you when you switch over
the director's role which i'm sure corey
can understand i mean he kind of
animated a little bit on god award too
and we kind of had to throw it all out
except for that sneaky back flip that
kratos has never done again that we left
in that's the perk of being the director
i guess
but you know from my point of view like
we want to tell a very
heartfelt and epic story as you know
father and son
go on a journey and they kind of
struggle with holding on with to stuff
and letting go of things you know it's a
very difficult kind of human condition
that we all deal with and uh we kind of
want to arrive at that by taking like
slices of life or family you know drama
if you will and kind of juxtapose that
against big norse backdrop
and you know at the end we just want to
have an ending that feels very you know
surprising yet inevitable based on all
those things but it's it's kind of you
know i'm from the midwest so like slice
of life very common mundane things are
just as interesting as big world events
and so we try to collide those things
together it's you know
make an experience that's very worthy of
the god of war name
so with the game officially being called
god of war ragnarok um i guess it
doesn't take a genius to think that
perhaps ragnarok factors into this game
in some manner can you confirm that eric
yeah i mean you can't call the game god
of war ragnarok and not have ragnarok
happen in the game so you know it's it's
gonna happen we're gonna cap off the
norse series with it um and i think
chris judge said it better than the
announced trailer last year prepare
yourselves
the last game ended with a teaser of
sorts for thor and i just got to know
was that thor's voice we heard in the
trailer just a few minutes ago that was
definitely thor's voice we heard in the
trailer thor's being played by ryan
hurst um but you might know him from uh
sons of anarchy he played opie one of my
favorite characters ever
and we're just delighted to have him
come play in the god of war sandbox and
his take on thor and our take visually
on thor very different than the hunky
australian you might know you know he's
much closer to the
norse mythology version you know he's
this big burly almost hedonistic
man-child red hair you know left-handed
just just a little off-kilter than the
thor that a lot of people know right now
so i can't wait for people to experience
more of that when the game's done
we also heard the name odin in tonight's
trailer so i imagine if we're gonna
experience ragnarok odin's gonna have to
play a pretty big role here right
definitely i mean odin is the all father
of all the realms so he's going to show
up when ragnarok happens
we are very very happy to have mr
richard schiff come on to play odin for
us you may know him as toby from the
west wing
this was one that we never thought was
going to happen it was like kind of a
shot in the dark and uh he got back to
us and we walked around the mocap volume
and he was like i've never done anything
like this before let's do it and so the
kind of rest is history so i can't wait
for people to experience that and see
how he factors in and it's a very
different take again much like thor and
he's like a
old man he's just kind of busy with his
own things and doing whatever he wants
and he's he doesn't live in a castle or
anything like that so it's a again a
different take kind of what we do we
just take what's known and curveball a
little bit and
you know make it special
we also saw a couple of new characters
tonight so what can you tell us about
them
are you talking about the little squid
oh no you're talking about tyr tier the
big guy yeah yeah he's the the norse
scott of war um and the critics and
tracer finally found him we talked a lot
about him in 2018 so we were like well
you might as well show them to the
people and then the last character we
saw at the trailer you know like with
the little winking smile from anger boda
she's one of the last remaining giants
and her story is pretty amazing and how
it fits into the world of god of war
tears being played by ben prendergast
who's been completely absorbed in the
role even though he is not a giant as
tyrious
and then
anger boat is being played by leia de
leon hayes who's a complete treasure on
set she's been amazing watching her
chemistry with the other characters has
been amazing and she's one of the last
giants that's living so we have those
characters and a few more and you know
there's a lot of different monsters he
saw in there and it's been so many
talented people at the studio building
this trailer and putting it together i
just want to give a shout out to the
team i love you guys you know i wish you
could be here doing this interview with
me i wish you were all behind me right
now at the studio
that would have been completely amazing
and you know lastly to our fans we have
a saying at the studio that we are fans
of our fans and i cannot wait to watch
all the tweets the messages the reaction
videos that you guys put out and our
team to be able to take that into heart
and just get excited and hyped and then
use that to push us through to finish
the game for you guys so thank you very
much
now corey we haven't heard a whole lot
out of you here tonight so now that we
know you're not directing god of war
ragnarok i was hoping maybe you could
give us a little clue about what you may
or may not be working on next
oh you'd like that wouldn't you you'd
like me to just spill the beans and tell
you everything that's going on right now
we're actually doing a bunch of stuff
it's really exciting all the things that
we're doing and you're tempted to know
what is this but i
don't really have anything i could talk
about right now specifically mostly
because we're really focused on god over
ragnarok that i am
incredibly excited that i finally
understand that that's what everyone was
saying god of war
ragnarok i was way off i was thinking it
was something else that they were
talking about i i think we'll we'll wait
to get any deeper into anything else
until later we'll talk again sid
all right well thank you cory and thank
you eric